près de 5000 antillais sont entrées en
Résistance pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale une page de l'histoire peu
connue et qui a pourtant compté une
exposition actuellement présentée à la
verrière revient sur ses événements
contenu de la population en général il
faut compter à peu près 20% de des
jeunes hommes qui ont pu s'engager ceux
qui rejoignaient soit les forces
combattantes britanniques puisque il y
avait des unités britanniques autour
soit aux États-Unis ou qui partaient
pour le
rejoindre les forces françaises à
travers Londres ou à travers l'Espagne
il y a eu un fort mouvement citoyen de
révolte par rapport à tout ce que les
différents populations avaient vécu la
garder en mémoire que l'ancien un des
présidents du Sénat Gaston monerville
était né esclave et c'était le premier
président du Sénat en 58 une résistance
matérielle et intellectuelle l'un des
plus célèbres résistants antillais
Césaire ce n'est donc pas un hasard si
l'exposition se déroule au sein de la
médiathèque qui porte son nom cette
résistance elle est passée par la
création d'un journal quelque sorte
qu'on appelle les tropiques ce qui
montre bien que c'était que les
Allemands le prenaient bien pour une
résistance c'est que la revue était
interdite l'exposition s'achève le 21
mai pour ne pas oublier c'est être aussi
vigilant et c'est savoir dire non
parfois ils ont dit non et pour convenir
c'est peut-être le message qu'il faut
faire passer